earlier this year we shot a show in
South Korea while we're in Seoul I visit
a fish market where I bought a live
octopus not to eat but to have as a pet
I named him Samuel then before I left I
donated Samuel to a local aquarium where
they put him on display and also inform
me that Samuel was actually a she okay
well guess what
all true I came back to Los Angeles and
never gave that octopus another thought
I assumed they immediately flushed her
down the toilet the second I left or fed
her to a crab you know but then just
last week true story
the Korean tourism organization
contacted us they said they wanted to
fly Samuel from Seoul here to Los
Angeles so she could spend her remaining
days here in our studio this is true you
see Santa whoa yeah it's crazy it's
crazy but actual yeah you see Samuel is
a year old which in octopus years makes
for the same age as Ruth Bader Ginsburg
so now
anyway this is all completely true here
is what happened just a few days ago
Samuel was removed from the Korean
aquarium brought to Seoul's Incheon
International Airport where she was
checked in as baggage she landed at LAX
and immediately started to enjoy la here
she is on a tour bus of Hollywood I
swear she was on that bus the two we
slow that down there she is taking in
the sights then she went to Universal
Studios where she tried out the eye
flight booth
well of course word got out that Samuel
was here in Los Angeles then she was
asked to put her tentacles in cement at
Grauman's Chinese Theater and she's
already found a celebrity life partner
ladies and gentlemen here's the most
exciting news of all samuel is backstage
okay and Wow
there's some mock enthusiasm Korea and
guess what gang this reunion is such a
big story there's also a Korean
television crew shooting this entire
thing isn't going to play yes
this is a big story in Seoul so let's
get around here before she dies please
welcome Samuel the Octopus
[Applause]
[Applause]
there is Samuel right there ladies and
gentlemen looking pretty good for her
age
hi Samuel good to see you again and look
at this we actually had this rigged up
this Conant aquarium check it out right
there there's a little toy desk and then
look look at the hair that's so stupid
anyway I really do sincerely want to
thank the Korean Tourism Organization
and their Korea visits you program for
bringing Samuel to live with us very
cool I also wanted to thank them because
now that they've dumped this octopus on
us we've already had to purchase the
maxi 130 tank with dual filters $12,000
neo stat temperature controller $1500
Coenen aquarium toy 475 dollars
tidal pool wave simulator $3,000
imported diet of northern pacific krill
$1,200 per metric ton full-time marine
zoologist 135,000 dollars chamber music
quartet playing a soothing ocean
soundtrack $15,000 shirtless latin pool
boy - cleaner tak
five hundred dollars therapy sessions to
help with the trauma of moving in with
tonin ninety thousand dollars costing
our show a total of 265 675
[Applause]
you